سنبله مدويه في القصر الملكي البريطانيه
قد يفجرها مسلسل من ست حلقات بكمل خلافا
كان قد شب في بلاطي باكينج الامير هاري
وزوجته ميغان ميغان ماركل يفضحاني اسرار
العائله المالكه وكيف تسرب بانتظام قصص من
موظفين بالقصر الى الصحافه ضمن ما اسماهري
اللعبه قذره اشاره هذه الى ان موظفينا
يعملون بالقصور الملكيه يطلعون الصحفيين
على اخبار بل ويلفقنا بعضها تفاصيل تعرضها
سلسله وثائقيه تحت عنوان هاري ومن جن
اصدرتها منصه نتفليكس تحكي قصتهما من لحظه
التعارف وما مر به من ظروف قاسيه
اضطرتما الى الابتعاد عن الحياه الملكيه
والانتقال الى جنوب كاليفورنيا منذ ما
يقرب من ثلاث سنوات حلقات ستنشر على جزء
هنا كشفت الستاره عن نصفها على ان الحلقات
المتبقيه في الخامس عشر من ديسمبر مسلسل
اعتمد على سلسله مقابله اوضح فيها هاري ان
حديثه مع بقيه افراد الاسره المالكه بات
شبه منقطع وعلى الاخص والده الملك تشارلز
الثالث وشقيقه الاكبر الامير وليام ولي
العهد ووريث العرش ليختصر القصه بسهوله
قائلا لا احد يعرف الحقيقه وحدنا من
نعرفها